bien que dans cette commission ce n'est
pas l'ex andré benalla qui est visé
d'ailleurs on interroge ce matin membre
du cabinet de l'élysée qui n'était pas
là au moment des fêtes qui était en
nouvelle calédonie qui était à dix mille
kilomètres en lui demande de réponse sur
des événements et en communication qu'il
n'était pas là on voit bien un petit peu
le manque de sérieux de l'opération en
l'occurrence moi je considère qu'on voit
bien que la commission du sénat se
transforme en juge en accusateurs en
procureurs et qu'elle cherche à travers
cette affaire plutôt atteint le
président cas vraiment faire la lumière
sur une chose dont on connaît tous
aujourd'hui